hey everybody it's garyvay nerdchuck and
this is another episode of
overrated underrated with me garyvee
[Music]
i'm here with my main man drock we are
happy and we are ready for the show
comic book comic books are underrated i
think uh in general
uh they are massively culturally
relevant and more importantly i think
that they have a potential to have the
next big wave
of collecting arbitrage similar to
sports cards
elon musk is underrated you know i talk
a lot about like shooting for the moon
and landing
on mountains the guy shoots so heavy and
i think he's young
and i feel like he's probably got like
two or three real big plays in him that
we can't even be thinking about right
now so i think he's underrated
podcast i think podcasts are underrated
i think in general
they are so part of the culture right
now that people
don't realize how early it is in its
progression
i think audio consumption will continue
to rise
because we are efficient animals that
love convenience over everything
convenience is king and audio
consumption is
more convenient and more efficient than
video consumption
i think podcasts are still early believe
it or not remember
ooh trevor lawrence you guys are
throwing me some
real heat i'm a humongous trevor
lawrence fan
i think he's going to be a spectacular
nfl quarterback
he is properly rated because he's rated
one of the three best quarterback
prospects
four best quarterback prospects in the
last 35 years so i'm gonna go with
properly rated on trevor lawrence magic
the gathering magic the gathering
underrated um incredibly interesting ip
hugely valuable cards black lotus for
the win
and the right age group right that nice
38 to 42 year old
age group enough money to really spend
on premium cards
i'm a fan of magic gathering i i myself
don't know a whole lot about it big
shout out to robbie turnick
who was on that wave when they first
came out i didn't see it at the time
but um magic the gathering underrated
crispy cream the og donut krispy kreme
the og
glazed donut is grossly overrated oh
hell no pretty big fan of junk food in
general
and just never got fired up
check one chick-fil-a is
overrated i think pop isis closes the
gap full disclosure i sit on the board
of bojangle so i'm in the chicken
business i think the gap has been closed
on chick-fil-a run hill stupidly
underrated a [ __ ] garage sale i like
buying stuffed animals for a dollar
and selling them for nine that's what
i'm about people like gary
you talking about saving money well i
don't make that much money i'm like you
could buy your dishes at the garage sale
garage sales are how immigrants like
live like they have it's how they get
their [ __ ]
[ __ ] in their house garage sales are how
kids learn that flip life
and become marketers and business people
and traders in the future
garage sales take discipline garage
sales build memories
my brother aj and i's relationship is
better because of garage sales because
of those
five years that we would wake up at
[ __ ] 4 30 in the morning on a
saturday pick his ass up and we would
[ __ ]
brother it up for six hours every day on
a saturday like
i'm about that garage sale life uh
cowboys
cowboys like the dallas cowboys
the dallas cowboys are overrated you
know an incredible iconic brand
um but they have struggled for two
decades and
they're overrated i think concerts are
overrated i know that the comments are
gonna i mean people live for [ __ ]
concerts and it's funny
they're overrated for me because i don't
like them overall
since i talk about this show from a net
net not my own personal point of view
i think concerts are probably properly
rated but i'm going to still go
officially
overrated bedding betting is underrated
show me the money it brings so much
more juice to a sporting event and it's
funny i was about to say i view bedding
the same way
i view alcohol and ironically both are
really great in moderation
you know i think both are both are
things people lose control on but
you know it's funny people demonize
betting and gambling but people lose
control with food
people lose control with over working
out people get obsessive about lots of
things
but i think in proper moderation um
betting is similar to alcohol it makes
most things
better for a lot of people tom brady
i despise tom brady and i actually know
a lot of people that know me sounds like
he's a fairly solid dude
i still [ __ ] hate him bts are we just
skipping tom brady i'm willing to answer
tom brady
i think tom brady has the potential to
be underrated what he's doing right now
i think has a chance to create a
storyline that creates
bill belichick being grossly overrated
tampa doesn't bother to jets so like i
think i hate josh allen more than
tom brady right now um i think he might
be underrated
bts bts is overrated and will
historically be but
overrated all those kind of phenomenons
i think struggle to be
long-lasting evergreen monsters i don't
know
anime is underrated i think i think
we're still
in the in the pocket of having something
go completely mainstream in the anime
world
when i mean mainstream because a lot of
people like what do you mean it's huge
it's [ __ ]
huge i'm talking your grandmother's like
hey what's that thing
that so i think anime is underrated
because i think it has that grandma
coming to you
in four christmases saying hey have you
seen this
thing and that thing is anime 90
alternative rock
i'm gonna go with underrated i think
it's forgotten
it's funny i think of that era and i
think a punk rock and i look what's
going on with people like mario judah
and things of that nature like a uzi
vert like like i love what's going on
with that rock
rap hip-hop mix both of those eras
and i wonder if this one as well they
don't last
as long as rock and roll or pop or
hip-hop they're like bursts they're like
intense for four years then they go into
their very small niche
that people follow the whole thing i'm
gonna go with underrated michael jordan
michael jordan
and everybody liked him so much and
thought he was so great but not this guy
i hate michael jordan i think michael
jordan is properly rated
dragon ball z i think dragon ball z is
underrated it's
talking about an ip that i would love to
own one day i think
you know when i think about dragon ball
z when i think of yu-gi-oh when i think
of
pokemon magic the gathering i think
dragon ball z is a sneaky one in that
era
so i'm gonna go with underrated ufos
ufos ufos are overrated
they don't exist tattooed tattoos are
underrated right now i think you know
it's funny i've actually started
thinking about getting my first tattoo
really yeah it's crossed my mind in the
last couple of months i think it's
really cool form of expression you know
get a little tear right here
i got how to get you drock let's keep it
going
rocky rocky iv underrated
[ __ ] i must break you i must break
you
like the yahtzee bia which everybody who
really really follows me knows is like
my favorite scene from any movie ever
rocky iv is crazy underrated shaman is
underrated
notice the conviction in my voice i
think he's got a very long
powerful music career ahead of him i
think soda's overrated and i grew up
living on soda warm soda big shout out
to my sister liz novello we grew up on
some warm ass soda russian style
fuller go easy on the pepsi
but i think in a world of spin drift
bubbly and too many alternatives at this
point i think soda in general is
overrated
i will say that i think soda is a
category that
is ripe for massive innovation
vetting machine businesses are
underrated they're sneaky as [ __ ]
amazon prime underrated amazon prime
is a [ __ ] beast that people don't
think about it's just eliminated massive
friction just it's such a big deal like
i think it's underrated i think it's
underestimated how powerful
of a commerce infrastructure then you
layer the entertainment
i think it's really underrated clothing
rental companies i think they're also
underrated clothing rental companies i
think are super sneaky
super cool have you know rent the runway
innovated so heavily back in the day
yeah i think i think people are starting
to get smarter with
stuff and i think just like cars
nobody leased cars i think leasing
clothes
i think becomes a bigger and bigger and
bigger opportunity they don't
they're not as adorable as a car for say
right
only so many times you can wear it i
think but like
i think underrated lionel mess i mean
he's widely considered
one of the two best proper football
players of all time so
similar to brady who's considered the
best quarterback of all time [ __ ] you
tom brady
i think messi's properly rated i think i
think he's more brady in the fact that
the world has given him his proper due
but i think when these players retire
you really
realize what they were because you take
it for granted while they're around
but i think messi is properly rated i
think freelancing is underrated i think
it's a really smart
move by a lot of people and i think with
the way the world's going
i'm so excited for the person that's
been in the rat race in la or new york
that's going to move to montana or iowa
or kansas or dallas or the suburbs
of new york and l.a freelancing i'm a
big fan i think it helps a lot of people
meditating i think meditating is
underrated but what it does is it leads
to thoughtfulness whether you're doing
it whether you're aspiring to do it
there's a conversation that wasn't had
30 years ago of like
hey take a breath take a step back lean
into perspective
i feel like i'm meditating 24 7 365
because i'm practicing perspective
gratitude thoughtfulness at all times
it's
why i'm so [ __ ] happy that's why i
always have so much energy so i'm a fan
i think that structure works for a lot
of people
avocados i think avocados are slightly
underrated even though they've had a
great decade
they were completely not on the radar 20
years ago give me an avocado with a
little salt and i'm [ __ ]
no i slept underrated underrated
being ready overrated kfc
i love what they just did with that
video game you know so i'm gonna go with
properly rated
i would have went with overrated but
this video gameplated
i don't i still don't think people
understand how much of the world's
information and entertainment is being
consumed on that [ __ ] platform
brussels sprouts are incredibly
underrated if you have not had one
get on that [ __ ] now i think spacex
is properly rated i think elon is
underrated but i think spacex is
properly rated i'm going space where do
you think i'm going
to the [ __ ] moon [ __ ] i hope you
enjoyed this episode of overrated
underrated please leave a comment
below on which you most agreed with and
the one that you most disagreed with
you